rape or sifsa Senegal's language a taboo
subject that rapper McGee addresses in
this song denouncing The impunity around
sexual violence against women in her
country
[Music]
the fight that she and her friend
Khadija a social worker are taking on
they say more women and girls have been
attacked since opposition leader sonko
was found guilty we saw that
though that was protesting they came in
some plants I mean raping them making
some violence on them I mean if you were
not with your brothers or others men you
know you are not safe they just come and
hurt you they just come and I mean rape
you
sonko has not been convicted of rape but
was sentenced to two years in jail for
corruption of Youth in other words
judges accuse him of debauchery in
paying for sex with someone under the
age of 21. the verdict thwarts his
chances to run in the upcoming election
ahead of the verdict he denounced what
he called a politically motivated trial
sonko denied sexually assaulting his
accuser 23 year old ajisar in a
statement many found his use of language
offensive and inflammatory he said if he
had to rape someone he wouldn't choose
one who looks like a chimpanzee kajija
says sonko's words have encouraged
violence against women in the trial
women who have been victim of serial
abuse and rape are afraid to speak out
and seek Justice
we want peace they chat at a women's
Gathering organized by the government
authorities are denouncing the violence
against women but rights groups accuse
security forces of arbitrary detentions
torturing killing of protesters using
live rounds
we're outside Usman sanko's house he
still has not been arrested the
opposition has tried to organize
peaceful protests but the government has
bound demonstrations saying it wants to
avoid further violence
for Usman Sanko supporters this is an
attempt to silence the opposition
KO has called on his supporters to storm
the presidential Palace and overthrow
makisal there are clearly populism in
Usman is someone who wants to lead
a people a population which is
99.99 percent black
compare a black woman to a monkey that's
a problem I think it's very very
problematic in a democracy
in this tussle for power between
President makisal and Usman Sanko Maggie
says women and young girls who are
victims of sexual abuse are being
ignored and silenced
a brutal consequence of this ongoing
political crisis Nicholas Hawk Al
Jazeera Dakar